sometimes the the symptoms don't show up
right away and there's a kind of natural
healing that can go on just by leaving a
war zone and sometimes not good to talk
to people we think now right afterwards
but rather to almost let the wound heal
a little bit on its own but some of the
symptoms were aware of and you know and
they will be hyper vigilance being in a
set hyper sensory mode so walk in the
perimeter or listening with a cuteness
the way you would in a battle area or it
might also be flashbacks inability to to
sleep or just one moment one of my
soldiers Rob Kissel oh just found
himself in a bar with his arms around
someone's neck he strangle this guy and
then and then he realized that he had
heard something and thought he was in
fighter mode and it just slipped into
fighter mode imperceptibly and that was
about a year you know after battle he
was in he was a long-term patient at
Walter Reed and being treated by the way
for physical injuries loss of our muse
titanium arm replacement in a and a leg
replacement other times it could also
just be this numbing that you you've had
too exposed to the sorts of stresses
that are so superhuman that you have to
protect yourself by numbing and you you
continue to dissociate afterwards so
those are some of the physical you know
the physiological effects that we're
familiar with but what I'm trying to
explore are the the spectrum that
doesn't necessarily may include some of
these but also includes the scarf
conflict feelings get sexual feelings of
feeling some guilt for what you did or
what you saw and did your best but
couldn't help to do even better than you
wish you could have done to survive a
battle when your buddies don't to be
part of an accident where yours no fault
at all no culpability but you but but
but you were implicated causally
implicated and you hold yourself really
accountable or to love your buddies more
than you love your
sir your family and you know one of my
soldiers said to me you know I've been a
tent with some one day in and day out
and I know and he passes wind at night I
know that fart you know and he said how
can I tell my mother that I am was that
physically close to someone so that the
feeling of a betrayal almost of your
home family because you've reattached to
others who've got you through it are
also feeling that life is darn boring at
home when you've been so wrapped up in
Reb revved up and hepped up that it's
hard to want to hard to find the same
kind of thrill an adventure even though
it's filled with danger